il est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur tvfils bonsoir et bienvenue
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction comme chaque soir du lundi au
vendredi et dans l'actualité de ce 10
décembre voici bientôt trois ans Imad
ziatan militaire de carrière perdait la
vie à Toulouse sous les balles de
Mohamed Merah sa mère mène aujourd'hui
un combat contre l'extrémisme elle vient
de tenir une conférence à Versailles sur
le sujet journée internationale des
droits de l'homme ne pas fermer les yeux
message lancé par Amnesty International
je recevrai ce soir le secrétaire
départemental de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme et puis changement d'horaire à
prévoir à Élancourt dans le cadre de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires un premier
bilan a été fait hier entre les élus les
parents les professeurs il a également
été question du contenu de ces temps
d'activité périscolaires
c'est en ce moment à l'Assemblée
nationale que se pose la question du
travail le dimanche un projet de loi
propose la possibilité à tous les
commerces d'ouvrir au moins 5 dimanche
et même jusqu'à 12 dimanche par an sur
décision du maire parmi les députés
yvlinois qui vont devoir se prononcer
Jean-Frédéric Poisson à Rambouillet
également président du Parti Chrétien
Démocrate sa position est claire il dit
défendre le repos dominical contre la
libéralisation selon lui l'activité de
ce jour n'apporte rien en termes de
croissance et il faut préserver des
temps de repos partagés j'en Frédéric
poisson qui a voici quelques semaines
déjà annoncé qu'il se présenterait à la
primaire organisée par l'UMP dans
l'optique de la présidentielle de 2017
Latifa non que vous avez sans doute déjà
probablement entendu son fils militaire
a été la première victime de Mohammed
Merah elle se bat à présent pour éviter
qu'il y en ait d'autres qui sombrent
dans l'extrémisme et le temps une main
aux jeunes en rupture dans les écoles
dans les quartiers déshérités dans les
prisons une parole qu'elle a porté
jusqu'à Versailles hier soir
était sur place
on ne peut pas pardonner quelqu'un qui
prendre la vie de votre propre fils mais
j'ai pardonné la vie qu'il avait parce
qu'il avait pas d'une famille pour
l'éduquer il avait pas un bon entourage
c'est un jeune qui délèverait lui-même
qu'il était en délinquant qui le fait de
prison qu'il était vrai lui-même il
avait pas trouvé je pense de l'aide de
l'aide de l'écoute une main tendue c'est
ce qu'apporte Latifa Benzia ten aux
jeunes tenté par le terrorisme depuis le
drame qui a touché son fils se mord sous
les balles de Mohamed Merah en mars 2012
elle mène un combat contre les dérives
extrémistes une association Imad
benziaten pour la jeunesse et pour la
paix et un livre mort pour la France
hier soir à Versailles elle est venue
témoigner la plupart des jeunes qui sont
partis c'est des enfants qui sont
fragiles très fragiles qui manque
d'éducation qui manque
une autorité
encadrement familial mais j'ai jamais
rencontré un enfant qui est bien réussi
et qu'il est bien élevé et qui va partir
en jihad je ne pense pas si je c'est
l'ignorance et connaissent pas leur
identité
les commercial Islam qui connaissent
rien dans l'islam que leurs parents ils
souffrent il y a beaucoup de choses
comme ça qu'on que je côtoie tous les
jours des parents qui appellent au
secours
à ses parents elle leur demande
d'essayer d'être plus proche de leur
enfant de leur donner de l'amour pour
éviter d'autres Mohammed Merah c'est pas
l'état qui va nous indiquer nos enfants
c'est pas la rue qui va dire que nos
enfants c'est pas l'école non plus
l'école elle est là pour faire l'avenir
à nos enfants on apprend l'éducation à
l'école une partie mais la grande partie
c'est les parents qui sont responsables
à l'initiative du groupe interreligieux
pour la paix des Yvelines la conférence
était intitulée vivre ensemble à leur
des conflits Samuel Sandler cheznezien
dont le fils et les deux petits enfants
ont aussi été assassinés par Mohamed
Merah était dans la salle pour soutenir
le témoignage s'il fait confiance aux
politiques quant aux mesures à prendre
pour éviter d'autres drames il craint ce
phénomène des jeunes endoctrinés qui
partent faire le jihad en Syrie cette
même processus que veut que qu'on fait
les nazis pendant la guerre
donc c'était la propagande nazie et
ensuite on a vu où ça mener
malheureusement je crois que c'est pire
que les nazis parce que eux sont fiers
de leurs actes les nazis se cachaient
latifa benzetten ne s'arrête pas là
vendredi elle sera devant les collégiens
de l'établissement Le Corbusier à Poissy
pour échanger avec eux
l'actualité dans les Yvelines c'est
aussi c'est fait divers 18 caves
fracturés dans une résidence de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dimanche le
gardien qui a prévenu les forces de
l'ordre après avoir constaté les dégâts
une femme a également été blessée en
début de semaine à son domicile la
victime de 77 ans a été braquée chez
elle à Saint-Cyr-l'École dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi et s'est retrouvé attachée
sur son lit les deux voleurs qui sont
repartis avec le peu d'argent qu'elle
possédait la sûreté départementale des
Yvelines est en charge de cette enquête
et puis une interpellation qui tourne
mal à plaisir un gardien de la paix en
adjoint de la sécurité ont été frappés
et blessés lors d'une interpellation
mardi par un homme en état d'ivresse qui
menaçait la gérante et les clients d'un
restaurant de la ville l'agresseur
comparaîtra donc devant la justice pour
violence volontaire sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
outrage et menace de mort ne pas fermer
les yeux sur la violation les violations
des droits de l'homme message envoyé
aujourd'hui Journée mondiale pour les
droits de l'homme par la présidence
présidente d'Amnesty internationale
France bonsoir pierre des gens vous êtes
le secrétaire départemental de la Ligue
des droits de l'homme dans Yvelines
associations loi 1901 qui agit à travers
la France grâce à ses différentes
sections locales justement aujourd'hui
faut-il s'inquiéter de l'état des droits
de l'homme du respect des droits de
l'homme dans notre propre pays en France
je crois que c'était surveillé partout y
compris en France bien entendu
d'ailleurs nous avons c'est le travail
direct quotidien de nos sections partout
en France de
d'intervenir là où effectivement le
droit est bafoué et je tiens justement
préciser que nous n'intervenons que dans
le cas où le droit est bafoué à nous
n'athérons pas dans les affaires
juridiques dont qui se déroule
normalement vous lancez un appel pour un
avenir solidaire avec des associations
des organisations syndicales également
autour de quoi tourne vos inquiétudes
aujourd'hui
cette inquiétude n'a tourné autour de
l'ambiance générale qui règne dans dans
le pays on a vu un certain nombre de
on va dire de force réactionnaires qui
se mettent en mouvement et qui essayent
de réduire justement tous ces droits qui
ont été acquis au fur et à mesure des
ans et des années de combat
par exemple les manifestations contre le
contre le mariage pour tous
il y a eu des manifestations aussi
contrôler quand on les francs-maçons au
siège du Grand Orient et ailleurs avec
des tags des trucs comme ça il y a tout
un tas de
d'inscription également qui sont
rates de nature racistes et vont tous là
bien entendu nous nous battons pour
l'égalité donc voilà tout ce qui est
contre contre cette égalité contre tout
ce qui est en tatouage au droit aux
droits d'expression au droit de vivre sa
vie comme on l'entend effectivement ça
fait partie de notre combat égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes l'égalité
des droits quel que soit l'orientation
sexuelle des personnes égalité des
familles dans leur diversité la
spéculation financière qui rythme
l'économie là aussi c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve dans l'appel pour un
avenir solidaire vous avez lancé tout à
fait nous sommes dans nous avons une
particularité avec le droit de l'homme
c'est que nous sommes ce qu'on appelle
une association généraliste dire tout ce
qui concerne de l'homme quel que soit la
nature les droits civiques les droits
politiques les droits économiques les
droits sociaux enfin voilà alors
d'autres assurances avec qui on
travaille en bonne entente ce sont
spécialisés sur un droit ou un autre qui
est tout à fait nous sommes généralistes
notamment sur tous les domaines et
d'ailleurs puisque on parlait enfin vous
avez introduit le la question par une
question économique nous avons tenu
c'était le dernier week-end de novembre
une université d'automne on obtient tous
les tous les ans et cette année le thème
de notoriété c'était économie et société
fragmentation ou refondation vous voyez
on est en plein là dans les droits
économiques et sociaux il y a d'autres
aspects politiques aussi pour la Ligue
des droits de l'homme pour un changement
comme une association civique et
politique
parce que dès qu'on s'occupe un peu de
ce qui se passe dans la société et c'est
même le sens étymologique de polytique
ça vient de police la ville de la ville
on fait de la politique
par contre nous nous engageons pas dans
les combats électoraux
nous nous interdisons et nous
interdisons à tout moment de prendre
position dans les combats électoraux
ni pour ni contre sauf des cas
extrêmement rares mais qui sont décidés
par le par le siège au niveau national
et
par contre non n'engage tous les
citoyens à faire de la politique il ne
peut pas y avoir de véritables
démocraties de démocratie vivante si les
citoyens s'éloignent de la politique ce
combat pour l'égalité à l'égalité des
droits à l'égalité homme-femme les
combats sur le plan de économique aussi
avec les engagements que vous êtes vous
venez de définir tout cela est louable
mais derrière quelles actions comment
concrètement vous vous intervenez avec
la Ligue des droits de l'homme sur la
section des Yvelines ah bah écoutez
alors la section des Yvelines et bien
écoutez d'abord on est on a plusieurs
types d'actions des actions sur des cas
individuels des gens qui viennent nous
voir qui ont besoin de notre aide alors
cela on le fait
de façon feutrée on en fait pas de
publicité bien entendu après nous avons
des interventions de nature généraliste
politique vous disiez tout à l'heure et
nous acceptons ce terme comme par
exemple pour unir solidaire c'est une
action publique politique qui a été
initié par la Ligue droit de l'homme et
d'autres et puis nous avons d'autres des
actions comme ça et puis bah
classique de façon tout à fait classique
bien on a des publications on a on fait
des manifestations aussi de temps en
temps on a des tracts on a des livres on
a un site sur lequel vous pouvez
retrouver tout un temps d'informations
tout ça c'est le quotidien et avec
l'appel pour un avenir solidaire qui est
donc lancé dans le cadre de cette
journée des droits de l'homme de
d'anniversaire de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme il y a aussi l'appel
des rencontres croisées vous allez
organiser des échanges tout à fait
tout à l'heure dès que je serai sorti du
studio c'est le laser du calendrier qui
est tout ça je vais à une réunion
justement pour organiser ça sur le plan
départemental donc je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui ce qui va en ressortir
puisque c'est pas encore fait mais sur
l'opération il y a la Ligue des droits
de l'homme mais vous êtes nombreux
on va dans les locaux de la Ligue de
l'enseignement qui vont aussi participer
donc bien entendu on parle aujourd'hui
des droits de l'homme dans leur ensemble
et peut-être un mot sur ces cet homme
qui a révélé c'était en 2013 lesionnais
l'espionnage massif du cyberespace
mondial par les États-Unis Snowden
poursuivi par les États-Unis pour
espionnage et il parle également alors
d'une vision conférence c'était à
l'invitation d'Amnesty internationale à
Paris les droits de l'homme bafoués par
la technologie ça semble presse
inéluctable c'est un domaine qui vous
inquiète aussi les évolutions
technologiques aujourd'hui ça nous
inquiète oui ceci étant dit je crois
qu'il faut poser le problème peut-être
d'une autre façon
la technologie est un outil
c'est pas la technologie qui est décide
derrière en amont il y a des hommes et
donc c'est bien la volonté de certains
hommes de s'incruster dans la vie des
gens alors parfois les vie privée
parfois d'autres la vie cachés et ça
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
est insupportable donc le combat pour le
respect des droits de l'homme évolue au
fur et à mesure parce que c'est des
problématiques qui n'existaient pas ne
serait-ce qu'une dizaine d'années
alors c'est c'est vrai par rapport à
toutes les technologies modernes
informatiques les réseaux les réseaux
sensibles ou les réseaux sociaux qui
sont surveillés tout à fait
l'espionnage la vie privée des trucs
comme ça saturiste avec d'autres moyens
d'autres outils parce que ils
n'existaient pas mais ça a toujours
existé et là ça hélas elle dit décembre
1948 58 États membres qui constituent
alors l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU qui
adopte cette Déclaration Universelle des
Droits de l'Homme à Paris on a évoqué le
cas de la France brièvement celui des
États-Unis à travers l'exemple de
Snowden mais plus globalement qu'elle
regarde vous portez en tant que militant
de la Ligue des droits de l'homme sur le
respect des droits de l'homme à travers
le monde cette fois-ci
je dirais bien triste regard un bien
petit tu regardes bon je veux pas être
trop pessimiste parce que il faut
constater aussi qu'il y ait des progrès
des progrès sans arrêt
positivement en tout cas vous qui êtes
militants actif depuis de nombreuses
années sur ce terrain là ça évolue de
façon tout à fait positive mais ça
évolue au rythme de l'histoire et
l'histoire a des rythmes lents
vous savez les Liga aujourd'hui
115 ans sans 16 ans je sais plus
exactement
on a reconnu un nombre de succès quand
même il y a encore beaucoup de choses à
faire donc c'est très lent et nous
vivons dans un système qui est on va
dire grosso modo démocratique même s'il
y a beaucoup de choses à
améliorer cela il y a quand même
beaucoup de pays dans le monde qui
vivent sous le régime du tétariale il y
a des pays où la Ligue des droits de
l'homme est clandestine ou les militants
sont poursuivés emprisonnés assassinés
même donc il y a effectivement beaucoup
de choses à faire nous les aidons autant
que nous pouvons bien entendu
mobilisation mais effectivement je crois
plusieurs centaines enfin plus dans 150
ou 160 Ligue des droits de l'homme qui
adhèrent à la Fédération internationale
des ligues des droits de l'homme donc ça
veut dire qu'effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui se développe pour éviter tout
à fait mobilisation journée
internationale des droits de l'homme en
se dit décembre et peut-être à l'avenir
ça vous fera peut-être sourire mais
c'est un sujet très sérieux journée
international des droits des animaux il
est en tout cas des militants qui vont
dans ce sens à propos de la manière dont
les animaux sont traités sont exploitées
pourquoi pas bon moi je suis pas très
animal mais bon oui pourquoi pas cette
tolérant oui oui plutôt quand on regarde
assez rapidement ce qui est fait aux
animaux enfin ce qu'on peut entendre
pourquoi pas bien sûr non mais je pense
que toute façon il y a déjà des
considérations au niveau de l'Europe par
rapport à la protection de la nature de
l'environnement qui vont inclure je
pense aussi c'est cet aspect là oui
certainement parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
d'animaux qui ne sont pas soignés comme
comme ils devaient l'être non
parce que nativement est un animal
c'est pas un humain donc non
respect de la vie tout simplement une
réaction peut-être par rapport à ça on a
porté par rapport au thème du jour bah
écoutez les Droits de l'Animal c'est pas
notre notre créneau à nous ceci étant
dit je pense qu'effectivement il y a des
animaux qui
sont l'objet de souffrance totalement
inutile donc c'est pas négligé
maintenant effectivement nous on est
Ligue des droits de l'Homme Ligue des
droits de l'homme est votre combat va se
traduire par des réunions prochainement
des rencontres croisées plus précisément
ce sera lancé dans le cadre de cet appel
pour un avenir solidaire qui a été émis
aujourd'hui par plusieurs organisations
dont la Ligue des droits de l'homme
concrètement on peut s'attendre à des
actions des animations dans le dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure que à la fin
de cet entretien vous alliez organiser
un petit peu exactement dans les
prochaines semaines non parce qu'on
arrive à la période mais effectivement
dans les premiers contacts qu'on a eu
parce que la réunion a été pressée de
contact on envisage quelque chose on va
dire pour le premier semestre et ce sera
l'occasion de revenir nous en parler
merci secrétaire dans les Yvelines de la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme aujourd'hui
10 décembre Journée mondiale pour les
droits de l'homme nous en parlions déjà
hier avec la responsable de
communication de cette société invitée
en plateau ce qui bus qui relance sa
campagne des bus de Noël après des
premiers arrêts pour collecter des
jouets pour les enfants des favoriser
auprès des écoles de 50 ans en Yvelines
le bus était aujourd'hui dans un centre
commercial l'espace Saint-Quentin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le grand public
pourra également faire preuve de
solidarité au cours du week-end qui
s'annonce Anthony Reich et Guillaume
nationale pour les images
les jouets sont piles depuis lundi dans
ce bus de Noël vous pouvez déposer des
jouets à l'attention des associations
une opération lancée par ce qui bus
depuis déjà 18 ans oui c'est important
de donner pour ce genre de
d'association et de
de don c'est surtout pour débarrasser
parce que les enfants sont grands et que
ils n'ont plus besoin de ce genre de
choses et les petits enfants n'en ont
pas besoin non plus malgré la crise la
générosité semble toujours aussi
présente certaines personnes offrent
même des jouets totalement neufs tous
les anges je me dis oh cette année on va
pas ça va pas il va pas y avoir assez de
jouets et puis tous les ans on en a
toujours autant donc je vous dirai ça
lundi prochain mais j'espère que je
crois que les gens sont généreux de
toute façon là on a eu encore des
personnes tout à l'heure qui nous ont
amené des poupées Barbie toute neuve qui
venaient d'acheter et qui viennent nous
offrir avant de s'arrêter devant cette
zone commerciale le but est aussi passé
dans les écoles et les collèges de 50
ans en Yvelines la distribution aux
associations sera réalisée ce lundi à
15h à la verrière les bénévoles devront
ensuite reconditionner les jouets on
redistribue à partir de 15 heures au
scarabée aux associations caritatives
qui après ont un gros gros travail
derrière parce qu'il faut trier il faut
nettoyer recomposer les jouets pour
pouvoir les offrir parce qu'il fallait
rien de de pire pour un enfant d'avoir
un jouet incomplète en attendant la
collecte n'est pas terminée le bus de
Noël sera stationné samedi devant
l'entrée de l'espace Saint-Quentin
après la mise en place de la réforme des
rythme scolaires au début de cette année
l'heure est aux ajustements ainsi à
Élancourt mère et adjointe à l'éducation
ont reçu mardi soir les parents d'élèves
pour un échange sur l'organisation de
ces nouveaux temps d'activités
périscolaire changement de rêve activité
proposée aux enfants était au menu des
discussions avec toujours une attaque en
règle de Jean-Michel forgot sur le
bien-fondé d'une telle réforme
ose des impôts locaux facturation
famille des temps d’activité
périscolaires les tap le maire
d'Élancourt en exclut aucune possibilité
dans les prochains mois lors de la
réunion d'information sur les rythmes
scolaires organisés mardi soir à l'hôtel
de ville à l'intention des parents et la
rappeler son opposition à la réforme et
surtout prévenu que la mise en place de
nouveaux services avaient forcément un
coût on ne s'interdit rien du tout bon
on va peut-être augmenter un tout petit
peu les impôts exceptionnellement seule
une ville très riche peut faire des
cours de cheval de piano ou des cours de
violoncelle c'est extrêmement coûteux
donc voilà donc on est obligé de faire
en fibre par rapport à nos moyens de la
vœu de Jean-Michel fourgousse c'est tap
ne se résume pour l'instant quasiment
cas de la garderie 23 comités de suivi
en place dans la commune où siège
enseignant et parents d'élèves font
remonter des besoins matériels pour les
animateurs des achats seront donc
effectués mais l'accent pourrait aussi
être mis ailleurs
si on peut donner une impulsion et que
je dis chaque on le fera mais c'est
coûteux parce que ça demande d'engager
des profs qui bien sûr coûte cher les
profs de déchets spécialisés soit ce
sera des cours d'anglais par
visioconférence et puis la troisième
option c'est bien sûr c'est les
tablettes vous savez qu'on a obtenu
récemment le premier prix de
l'innovation pédagogique par les
tablettes qu'on nous a remis au Salon de
l'éducation la réforme des rythmes
scolaires coûterait déjà quelques 450
000 euros à la ville et la facture
pourrai grimper à plus d'un million en
fonction des choix effectués entre
facture de personnel entretien des
locaux et des engagements de l'État
professeur et parents présents hier
s'inquiète surtout de la fatigue
ressentie par les plus jeunes pour moi
mes enfants ils continuent à aller à
l'école de 8h30 le matin jusqu'à 18h le
soir puisqu'ils ont à l'étude moi je
travaille je peux pas les récupérer à 4h
donc voilà moi c'est la première rentrée
pour mon fils pour l'instant je
rencontre pas de problème particulier
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut avoir quand
même un boulot avec des horaires assez
cool pour pouvoir gérer son enfant avec
des horaires comme ils sont proposés
actuellement
une chose est certaine les horaires
d'accueil des enfants vont bien changer
le quart d'heure de temps d'activité le
midi passera en fin de journée fin des
cours 15h45 fin d'étap 16h30 reste
encore à déterminer si ce changement se
fera dès la rentrée du 5 janvier ou en
septembre
et les comités de suivi dans cette
commune qui doivent se réunir encore
dans les prochains mois pour une
nouvelle évaluation de cette réforme des
rites mais une information politique à
vous donner à présent sur le canton de
Maurepas le PS s'annonce s'apprête à
dévoiler le nom à annoncer le nom des
candidats il s'agit des départementales
de mars bien sûr samedi matin une
conférence de presse sera donnée devrait
être annoncée la candidature d'un binôme
composé d'Ismaïla vannes conseiller
général sortant et de Marie-Christine
Mercier premier adjointo mère de Manille
les hameau puisque cette commune fait
maintenant partie du canton de Maurepas
côté UMP Yves vandeval lui aussi élu
sortant sur ce secteur en raison du
redécoupage qui a été effectué par
l'État se présentera avec la mère udaïe
de Voisins le bretonneux Alexandra
Rosetti
environnement triercé déchets pour les
valoriser une fois de la première étape
franchie lorsque vous mettez vos
produits usagers à la poubelle
interviennent ensuite les centres de tri
celui de Rambouillet concerne
spécifiquement les emballages et nous a
ouvert ses portes reportages mais la ni
pocket et William elle
bouteille en plastique peau de peinture
ou encore briques de lait voici quelques
exemples de déchets qui arrivent ici ils
vont être triés avec minutie pour
pouvoir être recyclé
première étape la cabine de pretri une
des deux sélections manuelles du circuit
de triage on enlève ce qu'on appelle ici
les grosses erreurs de tri en plus
parce que les opérateurs de tri ne sont
pas censés savoir s'il y a dedans et ne
les ouvre pas parce que ça peut être
dangereux sur l'année 2013 18,5% des
déchets ont été refusés
après ce premier tri 4 étapes se font
mécaniquement le traumel un cylindre qui
tourne comme une machine à laver grâce à
ce système les contenants tels que les
boîtes de conserve les bouteilles sont
séparées des corps plats que sont les
papiers journaux et magazines autre
appareil le séparateur optique le rayon
optique analyse le taux de transparence
de l'objet en fonction du résultat les
déchets sont orientés vers le bon tapis
sont deux étapes une première étape qui
va séparer les plastiques et deuxième
étape là c'est pareil les briques des
de la lumière grâce à ces machines la
qualité de tri approche les 98%. une
fois ces trois étapes mécaniques
direction la cabine de tri deuxième
manipulation manuelle et dernière étape
au total ce centre de tri traite 15000
tonnes annuels de déchets par an le
nombre de 2 kg augmente légèrement il a
une tendance actuellement à stagner mais
eastagne non pas du fait que les gens
prient Eastpak parce que la consommation
baisse et que effectivement période de
crise il y a moins de choses
qu'auparavant une fois trié les déchets
sont compactés pour être amenés dans des
centres de valorisation et ainsi avoir
une deuxième vie
culture pour refermer ce journal Tous en
scène c'est le nom d'un projet initié
par le théâtre de 50 ans d'Yvelines
depuis plusieurs années des danseurs
amateurs qui prennent en ce moment part
à la création chorégraphique d'Olivia
grande ville quatre weekends d'ateliers
au total nous étions présents pour le
premier d'entre Aurélia Debussy
avec son projet full Olivia Granville
propose une création chorégraphique
d'envergure une performance qui réunira
en juin prochain 150 danseurs amateurs
sur la scène nationale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pensez pour un
grand groupe full emprunte à la rue ses
gestes ces rythmes les plus évidents et
les plus mystérieux un inventaire
inventif des possibles figures d'une
foule de danseurs en mouvement vous
savez qu'il y a eu des danses orales
comme ça au début du siècle elles ont
servi en fait le régime nazi et il y a
toujours un petit peu cette idée là dans
un dans une foule que ça peut ça peut
vriller faire quelque chose d'inquiétant
et c'était ça que j'avais envie
d'interroger en même temps d'une manière
festive et en même temps en questionnant
cette chose là de qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire une foule qui fait la même chose
ensemble
les mêmes mouvements fait ensemble mais
dont les consignes sont communiquées au
fur et à mesure via des écouteurs ainsi
chaque participant interprète les
actions gestes ou déplacements grâce à
son smartphone j'ai travaillé sur des
partitions écrites des partitions qui
appartiennent à un mouvement qui est
l'électrisme et en fait c'est partitions
sont composées d'une de consignes comme
ça de d'action ou de pantomime ou d'état
à exécuter dans l'instant et en fait en
travers là dessus j'ai trouvé que
c'était vraiment une manière de se
mettre en mouvement extrêmement simple
puisque le mouvement c'est ce qui se
passe entre une action et la suivante et
que le fait de les transmettre à
l'oreille directement comme ça il y a
une espèce de spontanéité
d'interprétation sur l'instant qui est
très dynamique et qui est ludique et que
je pense les gens ont vraiment plaisir à
faire prendre du bois
s'enrouler avec une couverture
c'est surprenant mais je pense que le
résultat dans le sens sera assez
étonnant
voilà c'est une autre façon de
travailler on se sent un petit peu
commandé en général on a quelque chose
de codifié là c'est un peu de l'impro
sans être vraiment de l'impro vu qu'on
nous transmets au moment présent ce
qu'on doit faire donc c'est complètement
nouveau trois autres weekends d'atelier
auront lieu au cours de l'année en vue
d'une restitution finale le 6 juin
prochain
à demain 18h pour un nouveau journal
tout de suite sur TVfil 78 kiosque le
magazine de la culture justement très
bonne soirée